[Musique]
nous
pas besoin de légende on reconnaît tous
jean-moulin la figure de la résistance
une résistance pressenti lors de ses
années à chartres nommé préfet
d'eure-et-loir
il arrive dans la ville en 1939 dans la
lignée du général marceau figure
chartraine de la révolution qu'il admire
jean moulant veut tout faire pour
défendre la république lorsque la guerre
éclate contre l'allemagne nazie essaye
désespérément d'être mobilisés chose à
laquelle n'avait pas le droit en tant
que préfet donc il était de faire jouer
toutes ses relations il quitte son poste
en vain mais la guerre arrive à lui en
mai 1940
chartres se vide de sa population et
accueille de nombreux réfugiés lui reste
à son poste de préfet il reste presque
seul de toutes les autorités publiques
nous il se démène pour nourrir abrité et
protégé les populations civiles
et quand je dis qu'il se démène sait il
se démène lui-même avec sa voiture une
charrette pour trouver du pain ou de la
nourriture
le 17 juin 1940 débarque dans cette cour
de la préfecture les premiers
détachements allemand ces derniers
veulent alors faire signer aux préfets
un document mensonges et affirmant que
des tirailleurs sénégalais aurait
torturé et tué des civils
jean moulin s'y refuse il est alors
passé à tabac pendant sept heures dans
cette ancienne conciergerie de l'hôtel
dieu
il craint au matin de signer c'est bien
que utilisant des morceaux de verre
ramassée au sol les vitres ayant été
cassé par des bombardements il se
trancher la gorge dans la nuit pour
essayer de se suicider et il est
retrouvé au matin couvert de sang et la
gorge béante un suicide manqué qu'il
cachera dès lors sous un col ou une
écharpe un suicide qui préfigure son
engagement héroïque contre l'occupation
nazie